I am on the way to the studio we're
actually gonna be recording a song that
Andrew Lloyd Webber then I wrote
together when I first read the
screenplay and it seen the film is seen
through Victoria's eyes first thing I
said was we have to have a song for
Victoria it's an incredibly important
central part of the whole film Frankie
how it plays Victoria I mean
extraordinary talent there was an
ambition and an aspiration to have an
original song in the movie just very
much this understanding of like let's
write the best song we can I played it
to you and I said there's a new song we
said I'll do the lyric and you did it
then and there more or less if you dare
to what I couldn't believe was the
extraordinary beauty of these lyrics
that Taylor had written and it was as if
someone had come into the film I was in
the middle of making and you know read
the script and met the actors and seen
the world and reflected back to me and
under profound understanding of what
we're trying to do with the movie so it
was utterly thrilling Andrew was saying
you know it's this song we want Victoria
to sing but I sing a studio recording of
the song too and so when you started
playing the music it was just this
beautiful haunting melody TS Eliot is
such a specific type of writer and uses
such specific language and imagery and
so reading through like his work and
everything I just really wanted to
reflect that with it you can't you can't
write a modern lyric and for cats so
like if you can't get TS Eliot like
get to yes I'm here for you but at least
[Music]